[Musique]
servent à produire des batteries pour
véhicules électriques cette poudre
blanche c'est du carbonate de lithium le
prix de cette substance avait grimpé en
flèche au cours des deux dernières
années mais en quelques mois il a chuté
de plus de 65 % il y a une sorte de
pique qui a été atteint au mois de
novembre dernier où les prix ont atteint
plus de 85000 dollars la tonne le prix
d'une tonne de carbonate de lithium à
glissé sous la barre des 30 000 dollars
américains le prix du cobalt est celui
du nickel ont aussi baissé on va être
capable d'arriver avec des prix plus
concurrentiels pour le PDG de mobilité
électrique Canada un organisme qui veut
accélérer l'adoption des véhicules
électriques au pays il s'agit d'une
bonne nouvelle pour les consommateurs
des véhicules électriques entre 25 et
40000 dollars on va avoir de plus en
plus au fur et à mesure que un le coût
des minéraux critiques va diminuer mais
aussi
une certaine industrialisation des
processus de fabrication de batterie
mais qu'en est-il du secteur minier qui
voit fondre ces marges de profit avec la
baisse des prix
dans le monde d'habitude
on est habitué de vidéo puis des bas là
dans le prix des matières ça peut
peut-être ralentir
l'engouement des investisseurs mais les
investisseurs qui savent lire les
marchés qui savaient étudiés la demande
à venir je pense pas qu'on va leur faire
part avec cette baisse-là
n'est pas trop inquiet il souligne que
produire une tonne de sel de lithium ne
coûte qu'environ 10 000 dollars
ceux qui restent encore très rentable
pour les producteurs ici Philippe De
Montigny Radio-Canada Toronto